>> Laura: WHAT PAUL RYAN'S
DEPARTURE REALLY MEANS.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
PEOPLE SEEM SO SURPRISED BY >>
RYAN'S ANNOUNCEMENT TODAY.
I THINK IT ALL MAKES PERFECT
SENSE.
AFTER ALL, JOHN BOEHNER IS GONE.
ERIC CANTOR IS GONE.
NOW PAUL RYAN IS OUT.
IT SHOULD BE SET UP FRONT I HAVE
KNOWN PAUL RYAN FOR A LONG TIME.
HE'S A STAND-UP PERSON.
HE IS A MAN OF DEEP FAITH.
HE'S A MAN COMMITTED TO HIS
FAMILY WHICH HE SAID WAS THE
REASON FOR HIS RETIREMENT.
>> ALL THREE OF OUR KIDS ARE
TEENAGERS.
I REALIZE IF I'M HERE FOR ONE
MORE TERM, MY KIDS WILL ONLY
HAVE EVER KNOWN ME AS A WEEKEND
DAD.
I JUST CAN'T LET THAT HAPPEN.
>> Laura: ON A PERSONAL LEVEL,
THIS MAKES PERFECT SENSE.
REMEMBER, RYAN EXCEPTED THE
SPEAKERSHIP WITH A LOT OF
RELUCTANCE.
ON THE POLITICAL LEVEL, THIS
REVEALS THE SCHISM BETWEEN THE
ESTABLISHMENT WING OF THE PARTY
AND THE CONSERVATIVE POPULIST
TRUMP WING.
LET'S NOT FORGET HOW TORTURED
AND OUTRIGHT CRITICAL RYAN WAS
OF TRUMP BEFORE AND AFTER HIS
NOMINATION.
>> THIS IS NOT CONSERVATISM.
WHAT WAS PROPOSED YESTERDAY IS
NOT WHAT THIS PARTY STANDS FOR
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY, IS NOT
WHAT THIS COUNTRY STANDS FOR.
>> YOU HAVE SAID THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS THAT YOU WILL SUPPORT
THE REPUBLICAN PRESIDENTIAL
NOMINEE.
NOW YOU HAVE A PRESUMPTIVE
NOMINEE, DONALD TRUMP.
WILL YOU SUPPORT HIM?
>> WELL, TO BE PERFECTLY CANDID
WITH YOU, JAKE.
I'M JUST NOT READY TO DO THAT AT
THIS POINT.
I'M NOT THERE RIGHT NOW.
I REGRET THOSE COMMENTS HE MADE.
I DON'T THINK, CLAIMING A PERSON
CAN'T DO THEIR JOB BECAUSE OF
THEIR RACE IS KIND OF THE
TEXTBOOK DETERMINATION OF A
RACIST COMMENT.
>> Laura: AFTER ALL OF THAT,
THEY WERE ABLE TO FORGE A
PERSONAL AND WORKING
RELATIONSHIP.
>> WE TALKED QUITE OFTEN.
>> Laura: CAN YOU PICK UP THE
PHONE AND CALL HIM?
ANY TIME.
WE TALK ANYTIME.
WE TALK ABOUT EVERY THING.
WE TALK ABOUT POLICY.
WE TALK ABOUT FAMILIES.
WE TALK ABOUT KIDS.
WE TALK ABOUT EVERYTHING.
>> Laura: THE SPEAKER AND THE
PRESIDENT WORKED TOGETHER ON THE
TAX CUT BILL WHICH WILL NO DOUBT
BE THE HIGHLIGHT OF THEIR
COLLABORATION.
PAUL RYAN WAS GREAT ON THE LIFE
ISSUE.
HE EMPOWERED PORTLAND HOUSE
INVESTIGATIONS.
ON MANY OTHER FRONTS, HE LEAVES
THE HOUSE WITH MUCH UNFINISHED
BUSINESS.
THE HOUSE PASSED THEIR OWN
OBAMACARE REPEAL BILL, RYAN AND
McCONNELL WERE UNABLE TO TAKE
IT OVER THE FINISH LINE.
HIS LONG-SOUGHT DESIRE TO REFORM
ENTITLEMENTS, BIG SHARE OF THE
FEDERAL BUDGET, NEVER WENT
ANYWHERE.
THE TRUE TRAGEDY IS THAT RYAN'S
SWAN SONG WILL BE THE
NIGHTMARISH $1.3 TRILLION ALMOND
IN THIS SPENDING BILL.
IT'S EXPECTED TO EXPLODE THE
DEFICIT TO OVER $1 TRILLION BY
2020.
FOR SOMEONE WHO DEDICATED A LOT
OF HIS POLITICAL LIFE TO FISCAL
RESPONSIBILITY, THAT IS A TOUGH
LEGACY.
LET'S FACE IT.
SPEAKER RYAN WAS ALSO
UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S POSITIONS ON
EVERYTHING FROM TARIFFS TO THE
WALL TO FOREIGN POLICY.
THE TWO OF THEM REPRESENT
OPPOSING STRAINS OF CONSERVATISM
IN SOME SENSE.
ONE, THE FREE-TRADE, MORE
INTERVENTIONIST ESTABLISHMENT,
THAT'S PAUL RYAN.
AND THE OTHER A MORE AMERICAN
FIRST POPULISM.
THAT'S TRUMP.
THE SPEAKER'S DEPARTURE IS A
CLEAR SIGN IN MY MIND THAT
TRUMP'S VISION, NOT RYAN'S, IS
THE FUTURE OF THE PARTY.
PEOPLE MISREAD THE INVESTIGATION
MANIA AROUND THE WHITE HOUSE AS
A SIGN THAT THE PRESIDENT'S
AGENDA IS UNFOCUSED, UNSTEADY,
MAY BE UNPOPULAR.
IN REALITY, THESE INVESTIGATIONS
WERE THE INSURANCE POLICY
POPULISM THAT TRUMP REPRESENTED.
THEY NEEDED TO STOP TRUMP
BECAUSE HIS VISION IS ACTUALLY
PRETTY POPULAR AND IT'S ACTUALLY
WORKING.
MANUFACTURING IS UP.
UNEMPLOYMENT IS DOWN.
CHINA IS BACK ON HIS HEELS IN
MAKING TRADE CONCESSIONS.
ROCKET MAN IS READY TO FLUSH HIS
NUKES.
UNBELIEVABLE.
REGULATIONS ARE BEING SLASHED.
GREAT FOR BUSINESS.
EVEN ON ISSUES WHERE PAUL RYAN,
HE USED TO OWN THESE ISSUES,
TRUMP IS NOW IN HIS OWN WAY
MAKING A DIFFERENCE.
JUST YESTERDAY THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED AN EXECUTIVE
ORDER PUSHING WORK REQUIREMENTS.
HALLELUJAH, FOR THOSE ON PUBLIC
ASSISTANCE.
RYAN'S EXIT, LIKE FLAKE AND
CORKER BEFORE HIM, IS ANOTHER
INDICATION THE ESTABLISHMENT
UNABLE TO BE TRUMP IN 2016 IS
FRANKLY JUST OUT OF STEAM.
WE ALL KNOW THE PHRASE IF YOU
CAN'T BEAT THEM, JOIN THEM.
IN THIS CASE, IT SEEMS TO BE IF
YOU CAN'T BEAT THEM, LEAVE THEM.
THE ESTABLISHMENT MAY FINALLY BE